[Laughter]
[Music]
where are we at now
no we're in Las Vegas it's the worst I
woke up this morning with food poisoning
we ordered some sushi last night and
apparently it was not very good because
that was throwing up from both ends of
my body it was just the worst flight
getting here ever just like the words
once we landed I had to throw up again
couple more times and then now we I've
been laying down this whole time you
know hello that's better think you saved
me from having Oh
food poisoning could i order some
scallops last night and I just ordered
or wrong for you and I felt best I just
gave all my scallops to you and I still
don't want anything that's the one thing
that I didn't eat then you ate I feel
like that's what did you and thank you
so much I felt great
[Music]
hello we've been here we've been in the
city for two hours now we haven't done
anything
[Music]
all right so we are on the way to the JK
sweet computer it's gonna be a high in
Korea bit of life apparently everyone's
rooms are like five miles away from the
elevators you know took a golf cart
[Music]
[Music]
I know what were we doing advanced
brings those dollar instead everything
right gentlemen all your fingertips here
executive that second exposition here
its assertive Tom you're in control with
no pumps no no pops
listen sweetness weakness pops it's like
a jail sign like we alley how all three
of us it's like we're tourists enter
rich people place and we're like movie
so much alright we're gonna go find Joe
let me in the swimming pool because we
have the view of the pool
it has anyone looked up at you like no
they'll never know we head over all that
person like that yeah is it a person uh
it looks like a person Ben smile good
morning morning this morning and feeling
so much better last night we didn't
bring you guys but we had such a blast
we ended up going to do
it was a good night yeah I know it was a
good night we had dinner right but
before dinner oh my gosh I'm blinking
I'm trying to remember - okay
I remember what we did so instead of
getting a taxi van what we're trying to
do
somehow we stumbled upon a party bus and
we ended up just partying all the way
from Aria to Circus tickets and it was
oh my stomach hurts I just laughed right
now and it's like it feels like sore
like my stomach muscles cuz I was
throwing up a lot yesterday and I was
laughing a lot anyways I think that's
what happened anyway yeah we ended up
stumbling upon a party bus and I posted
up on my story oh and then after we went
to go play craps at Circus Circus that's
where we went there exact dollar table
yeah and so we were having a blast just
everyone playing craps and then after we
went to a diner
everyone ordered food and as soon as I
saw the table full of food I like whoo I
had to buy some equipment cracker there
and then I even I had to go handle
business in the bathroom it was pretty
bad I was throwing up like crazy but
then after I felt good and I was trying
to eat some soup but now it's a new day
and we're gonna go meet everyone
everyone's working on at the gym right
now I'm obviously not gonna be working
out I'm just gonna hang out with
Jessica's Jess isn't working out either
go see what they're doing
nice to go so I've been working out a
lot trying to get a six-pack and between
this trip right now in San Francisco I
like lost the entire thing are you
fishing for compliments No
I don't know what to say yeah that's
like I was gonna do some secret stuff I
don't even know if they say is it Roger
that no that's like military
Roger that copy that affirmative
military stuff I didn't know there's a
difference into military and secret
agent stuff watch the movies man okay
[Music]
that's good replenish your stomach all
right I got the mama and I got the baby
and then my baby got her
I represent the Asian to get the yellow
very easy variation which is very
Mexican of you
this is my marriage represented in a
well in this shot I got a digestion
[Music]
disgusting I'll tell you know it's good
for you oh my god I can't drink this
without going up like burning rope
[Music]
[Applause]
like that is so puzzling with [ __ ]
low tech and some emergency
what
he said oh wow better be bomb
[Music]
her lipstick matches my jacket let me
see that moonwalk real quick good on the
toes now alright we are now at the
stratosphere what do you guys do we're
you're gonna watch a Michael Jackson
impersonator and Gina's live streaming
right behind us are you big Michael
Jackson fan I love MJ I don't know
myself like a fan you know like what is
that it's a Claire oh it's from this
screen oh it's from the the screen
protector Bart is drinking what is going
on
cheers Cheers I don't know if I
mentioned this in the blog yet but I
never like drinking hard liquor ever
it's always too strong for me x2 morose
like I can do it and when we were in
so giving me suggestions on what type of
drink I should get and she suggested
Midori sours and can't really taste
telephone that much so now I've just
been ordering Midori sours though I know
that's it's a dream come true
and not just like the one karate thing
we went through with Noah you were the
only one wearing Aggie and once again
you're the only one wearing Michael
Jackson's face because I'm living it I'm
into it you know what I'm gonna do I'm
just gonna pretend that it's really him
cuz I didn't get to see him he looks
like on the way here yeah Michael
Jackson don't give him ideas right and
he's like you take
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you so happy she'll make me so
happy like the only show ever
if I had a key like 30 minutes into the
show I love seeing you so happy that
would maybe and made my night I was in
it
[Music]
we are going to ride scooters for the
very first time would Barton Geo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back at the hotel after
the scooter ride happy okay he has to be
after the scooter right we ended up
going to the craps table and we met up
with a lot of the crew cuz there's a lot
of us here there's like twenty three or
four of us here but anyway we met up
with the crew at the krepp craps table
sorry I'm a little buzzed cuz I had a
lot of drinks I didn't realize how many
drinks I was drinking when I was playing
cuz I just kept telling the drink lady
I'm like alright another one another one
enough I was like DJ Kelly but anyway so
we ended up coming up like crazy I
honestly feel like this is my most
favorite Vegas trip ever because the
fact that this is the first time ever I
come out like walking away from gaveling
up I've never done that ever I've always
lost the money I've ever gambled so I'm
having a fantastic time anyway yeah
right now we're gonna go ahead up to the
suite and then we're gonna have dinner
with everyone and then we're gonna go
catch a Cirque du Soleil show and play
some more craps
cuz that's the game that's the group's
game is crap because it's so fun like
everyone just gets it into the energy
and like everyone's energy really plays
a part in the game so having the entire
crew there and like taking up the whole
table is just so fun like so fun like I
honestly I mean I don't want to condone
gambling so I know it's not a good thing
neither is drinking or anything
honestly like everything that Vegas
represents is not good picking it like
that's something we should really
condone but yeah we're gonna go eat soon
me or all the other
[Music]
like American restaurants they give you
too much
when you go to fancy restaurants in
either you sit here and starve yourself
do not eat the bread eat your appetizer
and I do anything with an entree or me
all those things
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning good morning hello how you
feeling now
now that 100% I'm back to normal these
last few days I've been really babying
my stomach meaning like I've only been
ordering really light clean stuff and
then Joe also gave me some supplements
like probiotic supplements or something
and that I think that really helps so
I'm 100% now perfect timing because now
it's our last day we're leaving hey hey
we're going home yeah we're going home
now or going home tonight
Vegas is not really a place to flog
honestly we kept doing things that we
can't plug like the scooter thing we
really couldn't hold the camera on her
head I don't know how far do we I know
he was so brief he was riding the
scooter with one hand and then filming
with the other I'm like oh my gosh Bart
that's so scary baby doing any still
found enough time to use his hands to
signal to the restroom right how do you
do that oh and then last night we were
gambling again and luckily we're still
up so this has been the first and only
time ever that I've ever gambled and not
lost on my money this is awesome trim
the best Vegas trip ever
especially with everyone else everyone
was so down to like just hang out and
have a good time it was great time to go
home time the detox time to get back and
see Isaac I miss my baby we haven't seen
him for a whole week that's true oh yeah
because this is a continuation from San
Fran
oh yeah this whole week has been Isaac
spring week
yeah his uh his dad had plans for them
spend time together so then we made
plans to go vacation around San
Francisco then Las Vegas yeah and so now
we're heading back home we're gonna be
picking him up tonight and it's back to
the normal schedule
filled school tomorrow which means back
to editing vlog so I can probably start
posting again I know this whole time you
guys have been like hitting us up
telling I was like when are you gonna
upload another video like sorry guys
were living like I'm sorry no but yeah
hopefully you guys will see this in a
timely manner right yes
[Music]
[Music]